thank you everyone thank you for joining
um I'm niranjan uh I'm a data scientist
or I'm a manager from subex a Labs my
Charter here is to build hyperson Studio
which is a data science platform which
we are building for democratizing AI uh
I have shashankar uh with me who would
be cos presenter here he is also the
director of uh a Labs at subx right so
uh going to our topic uh that is uh
actionable counter factuals using multi
objective particles form so counter
factual explanations right so counter
factual explanations are essentially uh
the part of uh explainable AI in general
which which tells you what should happen
for a prediction to change right or what
should you change for the prediction to
change it describes the smallest Chase
to the feature value which this or which
changes your outcome right so that's
what counter factual explanations are
so there are multiple applications uh
for counter factuals in explainable AI
so typically uh from the use of
perspective a user might want to know
what cost a loan to get rejected right
and what he can do about it so that the
loan is accepted by uh by the Banks for
example but the bank or the service
provider wants to know what what caused
a decision uh what advice could he give
is is the model that is generating uh
this recommendation is it fair right so
these are the different applications of
counter factuals and currently it's very
important for us to understand how the
model works and how we can change these
outcomes or our make it actionable so
that this has a real world relevance
right so moving on to the next part we
have multiple challenges when it comes
to counter Factor tools there are
deciable properties from an explainer
standpoint that is uh it is looking for
efficiency uh the count of actual
generated should be done fast enough so
that it has real life applicability
right it should have it should be stable
uh when we mean stable is given a
similar query instances we are expecting
that the counter factual explainer to
generate similar counter factuals it
should be fair right the counter factors
generated should not uh it should be
valid regardless of their demographic so
there should be equal opportunity for
every demographic sense there are some
legal and ethical constraints as well
which comes into this requirement now we
also expect the explainer to generate
multiple uh counter factual so that you
know we can compare and contrast between
the different explanations
now moving on uh there are also
challenges in terms of what we are
expecting from the counter factual
explanations itself it should be valid
uh meaning we have some desirable class
for the uh loan say for example in the
loan prediction case right we are
expecting that the loan outcome uh needs
to be changed from uh the the negative
to to a positive so how what can I do to
change that and and uh when I'm
expecting I'm giving an input to the
explainer I'm expecting what should I do
to get this desired outcome that I want
right so that's coming to validity are
the counter factuals that I generate is
it valid minimality right it should
change the minimum amount of uh factors
for me or when it comes to machine
learning model features right minimal
changes in the features is is desirable
it should be similar so the the count of
actual generated by definition itself of
a counterfeiture we are expecting that
the instance the query instance and the
count of actual generated are similar is
it plausible right it comes into Factor
okay is the count of actual generator is
it a valid one is is it uh showing all
the characteristics of the real world
data that we look at does it have the
causal probabilities you know the
plausality and causality plausibility
and causality are similar terms here
actionability that I talked about right
and uh when we are expecting a account
of actual can a user action based on the
counter factual explanations that we
give
also diversity right for the service
provider to understand what the model
underlying model is doing he wants to
look at various possibilities as well
uh when when he's looking at a query
instance uh getting that multiple
counter factuals helps some reason or do
a causal analysis of how the model makes
its predictions
so the question is how can we address
these challenges right uh so for that we
have to go into how a count of actual
explainer is built uh so there are few
inputs that any count of actual
explainer takes in so there is a query
instance uh that is for which the
counter factual is generated there is a
reference population that would be there
available to the count of actual
explainer and there is also the ml model
uh for which we uh for the problem that
we are working on right
now how are these challenges being
addressed currently so you looked at
validity minimality similarity uh and
then plausibility right so uh when it
comes to uh similarity we can use box
constraints
and and Define as a search space in
which you can look for valid Solutions
uh when it comes to uh say for example
uh minimality right you can have
prioritization in in your features maybe
based on some importance and and other
aspects using which he could perhaps
prioritize certain features against
another
uh and and how uh and all these aspects
right we can also try to uh object or or
make mathematical functions from them
which can be used as objective functions
in your uh uh optimization problem right
if you are defining it as an
optimization problem uh when it comes to
plausibility uh or is is the counter
factual explainer explanation feasible
in real life right uh it can be done
using uh some uh data generation
approaches where we are restricting uh
the data generation to a population
distribution and using fossil
relationship within the data uh there
are other challenges as well right uh so
this is an example of the challenges
that I have described uh again in the
objective functions uh for those uh
desirable properties right how would you
uh Define those objective functions uh
how how do you translate that uh those
desirable properties in into a
mathematical function you can use for
the counter line
moving on uh for the other uh other
challenges that we described whether
it's actionable diverse stability and
fairness you can look at mutability
constraints right uh you only uh provide
uh the the features which are actionable
uh as as input to your uh counterfactual
explainer or those are the parameters
that the count of actual explain I
should work with uh we can also Define
some objective functions for diversity
uh say uh VR method uh generates a
multiple counter factuals maybe we can
guide that search process while
maintaining some diversity within the
data right so that's how we can Define
objective functions within that
and also you can use causal models and
protected attributes right that's
specifically for uh actionability as
well as fairness uh so uh why how do we
look at fairness right uh maybe there
are some protected attributes within
your data like a demographic your uh
ethnicity uh maybe you should have a
causal model which identifies uh all the
features within your data set that are
impacted by uh that particular feature
like ethnicity and then we can only
include the features that are being
unobserved by the the uh the feature
that you are trying to protect now
that's one way you can address uh
fairness right uh along with uh all
these aspects actionability or even
diversity we can use some post-hoc
selection approaches by which we make
sure that the counter factuals that your
ultimately
generating is is actionable and
undiverse right
and then there are some model specific
approaches that are being employed
currently so that you get stable cells
as well
now uh we are looking at the existing
Solutions right uh some or most of the
approaches that we look at uh uses a
multi-objective optimization uh and then
there are trade of interdependencies and
so on uh the the state-of-the-art
algorithms uh actually use random change
to the feature values and search around
the neighborhood of the queried points
now we we can basically definitely
understand why this is happening right
they are looking for certain desirable
properties when it comes to the counter
factuals that is being generated for
example what I've given here is face
algorithm right uh in in which they
ensure that the count of actual follows
the underlying data distribution so
these are the uh the current uh
strategies that is being employed by a
uh the the existing algorithms to find
out counter factuals
now how do you decide on an approach
right I mentioned there are many choices
for us how do you decide an approach uh
the uh the main answer here is uh not
all uh approaches guarantees or not uh
there is no single approach that
guarantees desirable properties uh in in
certain cases the problem itself uh can
be not actionable at all the outcomes to
a problem may not be actionable now in
that case actionability itself can't be
guaranteed by any algorithm right and
the strategy to adopt uh the methods to
generate these counterfactual
explanations definitely have an impact
on the properties decide so the choice
of approach is domain dependent or the
problem or is problem specific
now in our case we take a a novel
approach to counter factual generation
which is a simplified way of generating
counter factuals using particle swarm
optimization
now before going into the details of it
I'll just shortly introduce what is
particle swarm optimization right
particles form optimization is a
bio-inspired algorithm that looks at
flocks of birds or fish or schools of
fish and and try to mimic what happens
in in uh in in the the nature to to when
these fishes look for uh feed we know
that they travel by as a flock or or as
a school of fish how can we make or how
can we mimic that behavior when it comes
to searching for the solution to a
objective uh or or a problem right or a
loss function or an objective function
how how can we optimize that so we we
take inspiration from that and we look
at few different aspects of of that
right uh we look at a cognitive element
that is how much weight the the
particular individual has on his own or
uses his own experience to guide his
search there's a social element he
learns from
the entire population or the Swarm to to
know in which direction he should go and
there is also an inertial element which
describes how quickly that one particle
or individual moves in the search space
and how quickly it can change directions
over time right so this is how it is
defined uh in a particle swarm
optimization you have an initial
position and you update the position
using a velocity and there is a velocity
update uh equation in which you would
have all these properties that I
described there is a inertial element
there is a cognitive part and and there
is also a social element
now moving on uh now why do we use
particles from optimization here right
uh this is a simple approach to to
generating particles from why do we use
a simple approach in most of the
scenarios that we have we want a lot
more control on the uh outcomes that are
generated and all the complex approaches
that are available to us are are
difficult to modify for our specific use
case and hence we we are proposing or or
we have adopted a simplified approach
here and
um in in the case of large dimensions as
well certain approaches can be complex
and and can cause computational issues
so hence to avoid those we have stuck to
a simple approach using particles form
optimization
now some of the advantages are
especially again we can Define box
constraints in particle swarm
optimization uh it generates multiple
counter factuals uh so as I mentioned
earlier uh the Box constraints
especially help us in in controlling the
proximity uh or the similarity property
that I described earlier right so is the
uh the counter factual that I'm
generating similar to uh the the query
the instance that I give for which the
count of actually gets generated now we
can set immutable attributes so this is
with respect to uh sparsity uh as well
as uh when when it comes to minimality
uh or or uh say actionability right by
definition of that if you are setting or
one approach to looking at action
abilities to uh to uh avoid uh any uh
attribute that are not actionable for
the counter factual explainer right uh
and the particular variant of PSO that
we use uh it it you it handles
categorical variables or it considers uh
uh the particular the label encoding or
the one hot encoding that we use and
sticks to orbs to that structure uh by
by the the approach that we have taken
right
um and
um just uh in in the way we Define that
particular method right as we had seen
earlier we have uh using a mixed
discrete particle swarm optimization
algorithm in which the velocity update
equation and the particle update
equation has given us there and and
there is also an additional term uh
maybe if you notice other than the
inertia as well as cognitive and social
elements that is the
diversity preservation element that is
being introduced by the uh the usage of
the uh or by the choice of the particle
form optimization algorithm in in our
approach
uh hence uh why why that helps again it
helps us in in diversity and also it
helps us avoid some stagnation in in
some local minimum right uh and and uh
there are some motivations also right uh
uh because uh we are trying to find out
certain aspects of the algorithm right
we are looking at diversity we are
looking at similarity uh it it uh gives
us that information or our the fourth
element as our fourth term as I
described it it helps us enhance us or
gives us Solutions which enhance our
diversity subsequently also again we use
the clustering approach on the uh
particles that is generated uh by the
optimization algorithms and and then we
use clustering on top of that to pick uh
the the different points from those
cluster various clusters so that the
count of actuals generated can guarantee
some form of diversity within it
now this is how how we try to address
the problem of diversity right
um and uh when uh or what I talked about
regarding continuous variables and and
categorical variables right uh for the
the case of one whole time coding uh the
the the the positions of the uh
particular data points are mapped to the
nearest hypercube to restore their
discrete property now that's how we
address uh uh the the one hot encodings
that we typically use when it comes to
counter faction generate and hence our
method uh handles uh counter factuals uh
and and can take in inputs such as one
hot encoding or label encoding for that
matter
so this is how we Define uh the
objective function in in uh the PSO we
have again as an example here only few
properties have added here that is
validity similarity and minimality and
uh when it comes to validity here in
this particular case whether it's valid
or not it'll be a one or zero value for
that uh in in the case of uh
classification uh when it comes to
similarity similarity we are uh taking a
distance measure uh for how similar the
counter factual is to the query instance
there are also minimality aspects right
how many features are we are counting
the number of features changed and and
then that uh divided by the overall
number of features that you have will
give you an objective function for your
minimality constraint
uh so uh we are looked at uh how uh the
the count of actual explanation uh
objective function is being defined by
us again now once we suppose have the
count of actual explanations how how are
we looking at the Quality evaluations
right there is a proximity measure uh
which looks at how close the count of
actuals uh are to the data point that is
measured so it it just takes in the
average uh p is the number of counter
factuals that is being generated so
essentially it takes in the average uh
distance of the count of actual between
uh or from the counter factual and the
query instance so as you can see there
is a slightly different formula based on
whether it's a categorical and and uh
continuous value
when we look at sparsity as well right
how many features are changed so that's
also an evaluation criteria when we look
at how
how good your count of actual explainers
are and these are uh standard measures
that are being used by the current
approaches as well uh there are also
normalized diversity that is being
defined uh how are how different is the
account generated counter factors when
it's compared to each other uh
there is also coverage say in the sense
that how okay so you are giving uh
generate five count of actuals for me
how many valid counter factuals is your
method able to generate so this is also
uh another standard property that is
being uh defined in in uh any of the uh
current approaches or or any proposed
approach right uh and uh in in our
explanation again we have given that you
know or in the method that we employ we
have specifically seen that we can
easily control proximity and sparsity
now in in the approach that we are going
to describe this is the ways in which we
are controlling for proximity right uh
with the number of features changes are
being limited as I mentioned here we are
prioritizing certain features and in a
iterative fashion if you are generating
for those particular features or by
setting only those particular features
are mutable then it essentially controls
for one uh your proximity as well as
some form of minimality as well so uh
these this is one of our approach that
we have taken uh we are having box
constraints uh and uh again interval
bounds right for for the uh controlling
sparsity as well
now just looking at our algorithm it's
very straightforward
um so what are we doing we have the
inputs uh as described earlier we have
our parameters for the algorithm uh your
decision function the query data point
the training data set or the reference
population right and the outcome is a
set of uh count of actuals that you have
to generate now for each feature uh
again in the simplified approach we take
or find the information value which then
or which is similar to uh future
importance right and for each or or till
the point of uh or we are arranging the
features in in that particular order and
we can take in uh the top Edge feature
right depending on that's a hyper
parameter here right uh and and based on
on those uh features you are generating
uh the the particles right or we we
visualize the particles with with the
Box constraints and then we run the mdp
also algorithms to generate the count of
actuals now or or to to generate counter
factual uh uh outcomes uh now for the
specific count of actuals that we apply
or we can use a selection criteria in
the as earlier I had described uh we can
select a particular features based on uh
the the k-means algorithm so that it
helps us uh in in ensuring diversity in
our in our our approach right now uh go
going forward uh we we are selecting
those counter factuals and we can repeat
this process uh actually till till the
point we have generated uh the number of
valid counter factuals that are
necessary for uh or by by the definite
right or by the by the user input so
that's one way also we can ensure that
we have maximum coverage we are ensuring
for uh minimality we are looking at
similarity as a desirable property right
uh and then we are ensuring diversity
here
so that concludes uh the the approach
here uh we have also experimented this
approach and sensor this is a very
simple approach of generating amount of
actuals how does it compare uh to to the
existing solution or the existing state
of the art so in our uh experimentations
we have looked at different data sets uh
we have uh again we here we are
specifying what uh what are the
parameters that we are being used we
generate five number of counter factuals
for these uh and and we are averaging
the results across these instances uh
for the counterfection or or to when we
are showing the outcomes right uh here
we have uh again saying that okay
cayman's algorithm is being used as a
selection criteria so that it ensures
diversity within our data uh and uh we
have found that that essentially gives
us a better results than if we don't do
it so and then this is is how
it the the approach or the simple
approach if you look at it right in a
simple approach tax compared to whether
existing Solutions or existing Solutions
uh so uh as you can see it does not do
the best or it does not give the best
results in in all all cases uh we have
seen or we are looking at various
properties here and and and then in in
uh what I'm saying is that the uh the
the approach it's not uh the the the one
which gives you this most
state-of-the-art or it's not uh beating
the state of the art in in various cases
but as you can see the results are very
comparable and it's better than some of
the state of the Arts right so uh if if
a simple approach can help us do that
and it gives us a level of control uh
that that the other algorithms that are
faced provide right it's complicated to
understand uh but then then why not uh
so there would be some use cases for
this approach depending on the problem
that uh we'll use so that concludes the
experimentation results that we have
observed as well uh again uh to to put
it in the true sense of objective
functions right or or as a
multi-objective optimization problems uh
in in the future uh you know we could
perhaps extend the approach to use uh or
to to generate the Pareto optimality
front using the multi-objective
particles form and then select the
counter factuals with the desirable
properties from the outcome that is
generated so
um so changing the algorithm that we
have defined earlier into this is also
fairly straightforward
the only change is that the
multi-objective particles form
optimization actually uses a reference
set an additional reference set to
maintain a list of non-dominated
solutions which which are being used as
a global or for the global search of of
the particular positions of the
particles right so we'll start to cut
you off but uh we've got about like one
minute left yeah we might wanna yeah
sorry for that thank you sure thank you
yeah so uh uh so to come to a conclusion
right so what we have seen is that a
simple approach to a particles form or a
simple approach using particles form
gives us control or ability to control
the various uh properties that we need
and is comparable to the current state
of the Arts and and this uh I hope uh
shed some light on on the various topics
of count of actual explanations as well
as particles form how how we can look at
the different properties of a particle
swarm optimization and so on right uh I
hope uh I I I was able to give some shed
some light on on the topic now thank you
and uh